a 17-year-old child he was all alone
with him he took a baby from me
he was still a child he
needed his mother
this morning he gave me a big kiss he
told me mum I love you I tell him take
care of yourself then I love you take
care of yourself here we
went out at the same time he left for a McDo I left for
work like everyone else
1 hour later they tell me what they shot
my son
do what I only have one I have not 10 I
only have one it was my life he was my
best friend he was my son he was my
it was all for me we were complicit
as not possible
thank you very much for your support or there
thank you very much thank you very much
I don't know what to say thank you